uh today we have uh an exciting session
ahead of us
the speakers are matthieu guest nevina
latisse
peter rabil and martha white and we'll
have a discussion
afterwards at 11 30 pacific time
uh on optimization hosted by gregory noe
um without further ado let's get started
with
uh nevina and uh
looking forward to talking abina so i'll
let you start sharing your slides
okay thanks for uh organizing
um
oops
i advanced a few slides when i was
testing
um so uh oops
sorry um yes
the title of my talk is going to be
adaptive approximate policy iteration
and this is joint work with the botta
yasi nabasiyat kori puyo julani and java
sapeshwari
the setting is going to be learning and
markov decision processes
with observed states x discrete actions
a unknown reward function r and unknown
dynamics
pi will denote the stochastic policy q
pi
will denote the action value of policy
pi
and we will be in the infinite horizon
undiscounted setting
um where the goal is to find a policy
that
maximizes the average reward
and we will assume that the mdp is also
ergodic so that everything is
well defined and the learning protocol
will be
online single trajectory learning where
we compare
algorithms in terms of their regret
where the regret here is defined as the
difference between
the average reward of the optimal policy
um
and the rewards accumulated by the
alberta
um so in terms of related work
on this topic there are a lot of
rl algorithms out there with sublinear
regret guarantees
but most of them either require a finite
state action space so
a tabular mdp or a finite horizon
or both and this is with the exception
of some
recent results on infinite horizon
linear mvps
so in this talk i'll focus on the
infinite horizon case where the state
space is also very large
possibly infinite so we have to use a
function approximation
i'll describe two algorithms for this
setting which
achieves sublinear regret called
polytechs and aapi
and both are kind of versions of
approximate policy iteration
where you regularize each policy to the
previous
policy in terms of kl divergence
and so the main difference is just that
in aapi
uh the this regularization is kind of
going to be adaptive
um so it's probably best to first
describe the vanilla version of
approximate policy iteration
it basically alternates between a policy
valuation stage and a policy improvement
stage
in the policy evaluation stage you
execute the current policy for some
number of steps
and estimate its q function and in the
policy improvement stage
you set the next policy to be greedy
with respect to that
q function estimate and so if these q
functions are
exact there's no error this is
guaranteed to converge to the optimal
policy
but with function function approximation
this
tends to work poorly in practice and
it's not even
guaranteed to converge
and so politics is a version of
approximate policy iteration
which uh modifies the policy improvement
step
so instead of being greedy with respect
to the most recent q
function estimate we also add to the
objective the kl divergence
um to the previous to the policy of the
previous iteration
and so i guess superficially this kind
of also looks like some popular
algorithms like trpo makes that trpo
reverses the kl divergence and uses a
constraint
but really for us the motivation for
this update comes from
online learning and so this can be seen
as running mirror descent in each state
x
where the loss functions or the reward
functions i guess to the mere descent
algorithm
are the q functions q hat of x in each
iteration and so this arg max can also
be computed in
exact form and what you end up getting
is a boltzmann policy
over the sum of all the previous q
functions
and aapi is also a similar algorithm
and the main difference is that instead
of mirror descent
we update the policy using a different
online learning
algorithm so instead of a mere descent
in each state we use
adaptive optimistic fdrl
and basically the idea behind these
optimistic
mirror descent versions is that the
reward functions
that you that you keep receiving are not
adversarial but instead you have some
side information at each iteration
which is predictive of the next reward
function
and so um when we apply this to uh
policy iteration our reward functions
are q functions
and so like because the policies are
changing slowly because of the kl
regularization
uh the corresponding queue functions of
these policies are also kind of changing
slowly
and so we can use the current queue
function um
to predict the next one and when you
plug that stuff
into the ao ftrl update rule
um you get a policy that's kind of
similar to politics
but a little bit different so the
differences are here i guess highlighted
in
purple um it's again a boltzmann policy
over the sum of all previous q function
estimates
but we are double counting the most
recent
q function estimates and also the
boltzmann temperature
is kind of adaptive so it's a function
of the current state
and also all the previous q function
estimates
and basically like if all the previous q
functions
if the consecutive ones actually um
agree
um on in in the current state x
then this policy is a little bit more uh
greedy in state x
and if the consecutive um q functions
uh disagree a lot in the state x then
the policy ends up being a bit more
stochastic
[Music]
um so in terms of the regret guarantees
uh what we can show is that if these q
function estimates are good in some
sense
um then the regret of polytechnic scales
as
t to the three-fourths and of aapi
as t to the two thirds where the main
difference is
due to the different online learning
algorithm
and the thing that we require the q
function estimates to satisfy is
uh when we estimate the q function from
tau
samples the error scales is one over
square root tau
and this error is weighted in the
stationary state action distribution
of the optimal policy um
and so you might wonder when does uh
this assumption q function
error hold um we can show that
it holds at least in some cases um
for example in linear ergodic mdps where
all the q functions are linear
and some known features if we also
assume that
all the policies produced by the
algorithm span the feature space
so no policy just lives in a subspace of
the features
and we estimate the weights using the
lsp algorithm um
then this air assumption is going to
hold um but
i guess effectively these assumptions on
ergodicity
and feature excitation kind of
circumvent the need to
um explore so and more general
environments which are
less stochastic i think one would also
need to
do some exploration to get a good
estimate of each
q function um
so in terms of the way that uh the
analysis works
it's based on um this uh
paper called online mvps by avindar
kakaden mansour
which as far as i know was the first one
to propose
doing reinforcement learning by running
online learning in each state
and so their setting was a bit different
in that they assumed that tabular mdp
with known dynamics
and adversarial reward functions
but a lot of the analysis still applies
and basically what we do is
we we first add and subtract
the average uh the average reward of
each intermediate policy
j pi k and decompose the regret that way
so then in the top equation on the right
the second term is just the difference
between the true
average reward and the empirical average
um
of each policy so that's not too
difficult to bound
and for the first term this j star minus
j
pi k we rewrite it using the performance
difference llama
and then what we get is this difference
of q functions
evaluated at the optimal policy minus q
functions
um evaluated at the intermediate
policies
and so this last term if you look at it
it kind of looks like
the regret of an online learning
algorithm
whose reward functions are q pi k
and so for that part we can just use the
regret of mirror descent orb or
optimistic mirror descent and we also
have to take into account
the policy evaluation error
so that's basically how it works um
some limitations of this approach
are that as i mentioned before um
we don't do any explicit exploration so
this is more about just like optim
optimization um we circumvent this using
the ergodicity assumption and feature
excitation
but i guess uh more general algorithm
would also do
exploration and account for that in the
regret
another uh direction for improvement is
improving the regret dependence on t
so i regret bound scales scale as uh t
to the three-fourths and two-thirds
but the known lower bound at least for
the tabular case
is uh square root t um
and so some ways to improve um
the balancer for example uh instead of
estimating hq function
using the tau on policy samples uh
we could try to use all the previous
samples either using some sort of ope
or a model and
i guess that if we could show a better
finite sample
uh error bound for the uh evaluation
error
um then we could also improve the regret
um another uh limitation or direction
for future work is
improving constants so i guess i didn't
discuss this on the
on the previous slide but um in terms of
the content constants multiplying
uh multiplying the
the t term um polytext does not depend
on the number of states
like in the linear case it will just
depend on the number of features
but when we analyze aapi we do get a
term which can potentially be as big as
the size of the state space
i think this is not a fundamental
problem but more like our algebra
problem
so it's something that needs to be
improved in the analysis
and the final direction for future work
is
memory efficient implementation
so if you look at the all these
algorithms as i've described them
if you implement them with neural
networks they can be pretty memory and
efficient
uh because each policy is a sum of
um as boltzmann over the sum of all past
q
q function estimates and so if you uh
estimate each hq function using a neural
network
you kind of have to store the parameters
of all these past neural networks
in memory um and um
and also the policy becomes pretty slow
because you have to evaluate all those
uh neural networks at each step and
similarly for the boltzmann temperature
um so there are some ways of getting
around this
you could subsample the q functions um
you could
do distillation so approximate the sum
with a single network
um and the third option is to
parameterize the policy
and then minimize the minimize the
objective with respect to the policy
parameters
so this is uh another direction for us
for
future work basically doing this in a
memory efficient way
and then incorporating the optimization
error into the
regret um
[Music]
so finally i'll just show some
experiments
so this first set of experiments
are on a simple tabular ergodic mdp
where we can just implement everything
exactly and this environment is
very stochastic so we don't really need
to do much exploration
and the different plots just correspond
to different
number of states and actions uh so here
i just compared
politics um aapi and another algorithm
called
rlsvi which basically randomizes
value function parameters and so
here it seems like this
adaptive regularization
does help api converge
faster than politics
um here are some
other experiments in a in a i guess
slightly different
environment which is not stochastic at
all actually the dynamics are
deterministic
and it does require a little bit of
exploration so here this
um diver starts in the top uh
left corner and he can go either
down and to the left and receive a
reward of zero or
down and to the right and receive a
reward of minus one
but kind of has to he keep swimming to
the right to get the treasure
and in the infinite horizon version we
just kind of wrapped
on the y-axis uh so he keeps swimming
around
um in this case we tried uh linear value
function approximation
where the feature vectors just have the
x y coordinate
of the swimmer and um
and we didn't really do anything about
the exploration we just sort of uh
for larger goods we just made the phase
lands longer so
the initial uh policies have some chance
of
um of seeing the on the treasure
um and here again like it seems like um
even though the assumptions don't hold
and actually we implement implemented
the
the boltzmann temperature sort of
approximately by subsampling the
value functions um api is still
converged a bit faster than polytechs
um but on card poll we saw
slightly negative results so here i
guess like the
the standard deviations do overlap a
little bit this is uh
um i guess averaged over 50 different
trends
but uh in cardboard um
api was a little bit worse than
polytechs we're not quite sure why but
maybe in the case where sort of
the observations uh change smoothly this
adaptive birth states learning rate
doesn't really help too much
and that's the end of my talk um
so any questions
all right fantastic nevina thank you so
much uh
we are actually uh quite on time so
there's plenty of time
for questions and possibly also for uh
trying to make sure that mathieu's
microphone works
matthew did you have a question
um
so i missed the talk unfortunately but
can you hear me
we can hear you so that's uh yeah so
that's a good question
uh thank you matthieu so um
uh well let me open up the floor then to
uh to other questions
so i actually do have a question uh
naven i really like this idea of uh
using optimistic updates in this mere
decent
steps that you're using but i'm just
wondering if it actually
helps the optimization procedure or
dealing with the
with the estimation errors or where
exactly
does the improvement manifest itself
yeah i think uh so for the evaluation
error we just use
uh the same evaluation procedure um
for both uh polytechs and api i think it
just helps with the optimization um
regarding that my second question would
be that if you would have like
perfect evaluation like perfect q
functions and everything
do you think that this optimistic trick
would actually like
uh improve the convergence guarantees
for standard mirror descent or maybe
even improve over the standard
policy iteration guarantees
um yeah i think so i i mean
uh we are using the optimistic version
because
um i guess the regret uh just for the
online learning
algorithm is better so it's supposed to
converge faster
um yeah if you had perfect perfect q
functions i guess you could just use
uh regular greedy policy iteration
um whenever i've tried that like that
converged faster than mirror descent or
this so if with perfect few functions i
guess you could just be
like really greedy um but um
i guess with some error this
does seem to help converge faster
i see i was just particularly wondering
if you could get like a geometric rate
uh for the evaluation error for this
update
um yeah at the rate of like one over t
but yeah i guess this is a
rather fine question
yeah we just i have one already but
all right that's great thank you very
much thank you
i have a quality question to that um
that's really interesting though that
was helpful for understanding more where
the wind is coming in
so you're saying if you have perfect
action values like your q
hat k was perfect then you should you
shouldn't use this sum of action values
into the past like as a boltzmann
distribution but you should just act
greatly according to those q
that's what you're saying right uh i
mean yeah
the greedy policy situation with perfect
few functions
is guaranteed to converge to the optimal
policy
i don't know how fast it is actually
um but um i guess you don't have this
need to damp to the previous policies
wonderful okay i had actually a question
about the experiments too there those
those experiments were very nice there
were new ones they kind of told us where
it fails where it does well
i was curious about one of the plots um
not this one the one right before
you had there was yeah and deep cn is
equal to 15 there's sort of this part
where
it gets worse it's maybe one of the runs
is
is getting really bad or something do
you know what's happening and n is equal
to 50 in there
yeah yeah i think uh the that is the
case like one of the runs is just
starting to go to the left as opposed to
going to the right i think like this is
a little bit of a tricky
environment when you wrap the axis like
in the episodic version all you have to
do is like keep going to the right
but if you wrap the y-axis the optimal
policy will
go to the right initially and then go
left right left right left right
just staying close to the right edge um
so uh maybe some of the policies are
starting to drift more to the left
uh dislike my guess on what's going on
um
uh in deep sea
okay i do have one more question maybe
others have questions actually i can see
those other questions i'll wait
go ahead martha well while we have you
on the call okay sounds good um
so so this this point about improving
the optimization when we have action
values that have errors in them
um i think you sort of highlighted that
there's nothing specific what
exploration that you're doing here
uh but is this averaging over past
action values
then using this pulse distribution
actually also giving you some
exploration that's helping improve
performance or do you think that has no
impact
um i think um i don't think it's giving
us
exploration because basically like over
time the boltzmann policy is just
getting more greedy
uh i think it's maybe helping helping
with the q function
error like if you think of each queue
function as some sort of like a noisy
ranking of actions uh then when you like
average those noisy
rankings like maybe you get a better
like action
ranking uh so it might be helping with
the error well like in terms of
exploration
i think um yeah it's just getting more
greedy over time um
i think like the api rule like it's a
little bit like kind of interesting that
um where is it um
yeah so this adaptive boltzmann
temperature it's kind of weird like
if all your q functions agree on a state
then it makes the policy more greedy
and if they disagree they they make the
policy more stochastic
at a particular state so that
kind of looks a little bit more
exploratory than just using the same
uh boltzmann temperature but like from a
theoretical like standpoint we can't
really say much about
this and exploring the state space
okay great thanks
there is a question in the chat um maybe
if there are no direct questions
uh from the panelists i'll take i'll
bring that up um the question is from
sharon vaswani and it is when politics
api fail do you have a sense of whether
it is because of a stochastic
optimization problem
so the problem with the step size or
because of the lack of exploration i
think
martha asks some of this but maybe you
can reiterate the point and
answer um i think it's mostly because of
the
lack of exploration and so sort of like
the q function error
that's my sense
uh fantastic gargoyle you had a point
you wanted to make
oh no not quite i'm just hoping that
that matcha is going to be able to talk
about this i was just saying that
averaging past q values actually
probably helps
in mitigating the effects of uh of
evaluation errors
and might have some cool papers about
this but but yeah he's going to go into
that hopefully
i actually have a question about this um
with regards to material can be wrong or
right but uh
nevina the the algorithms you've
presented them here
to me as a practitioner seem incredibly
conservative
the fact that you're uh you know
you're you're so dependent and such a
long history of old
policies now online learning algorithms
are typically
designed to be conservative because of
adversarial constraints but there's no
other short constraints here so is there
something we can do better
if we know the world is friendly
yeah i guess so i mean like on one
extreme you just have regular
policy iteration which i guess would
just
maybe give you a boltzmann policy with
respect to the most recent q function
right if you just regularize with
entropy
and this is like looking at the sum of
all the past q functions
i i think like maybe maybe something in
between
is um like just keeping a buffer of the
most recent one or sub-sample
uh some of the past q functions just
sort of to prevent
um standard policy iteration from um
oscillating basically make it make it
converge and slow it down a little bit
but maybe not look at the whole history
i wonder actually in online learning
there's this technique called switching
or uh you know fixed sharing used to be
called that was actually exactly
designed for if your environment changes
quickly you can sort of
catch up on it i wouldn't i don't know
if that's been looked at at all but that
could be
quite neat um yeah
i guess here we're just uh assuming that
everything is uh
the same or like the environment doesn't
change uh
though the distribution of state state
action pairs do change because of
different policies
yeah but it's interesting yeah um
we have time for one more question
matthew i think you are going to chime
in so if you would like to chime in
uh yes i was just about to say that
averaging is good and even if you have
all past
functions the thing is that
it's a true average in the sense that
i will talk about a bit of this later
but
uh assume that you have a transformation
method like in tier q where you say
i don't want my policy to be too far
from the previous one with the combat
club about the veterans
what you do implicitly is that you use
this kind of technique
you you consider all pascal functions
because this is
inside the produce policy so
it makes sense and even if
it doesn't learn actually
sorry i didn't really understand the the
last part uh
but i understood the the comment about
trpo
i'll just stop pushing is that
so i um unfortunately missed the talk
but uh you should take politics
you can see politics as a kind of
followers or realized leader right
but follow the regular leader you can
see it as a kind of mirror distance
and mirror descent is basically i just
want
uh i want my policy to be not too greedy
i just want my policy to be uh
close to the previous one and when you
do optimization it's the same thing you
do a linearization of the function and
you say
i want to optimize this linear
resolution by not moving too far from my
current estimate
but this current estimate it implicitly
uh account for all past previous
estimates
so it's what i'm saying it's not
a very conservative because
if you say i don't want to move too far
from where i am
where you are depends on where you are
before and before before so we just
different writing of the same idea
okay thank you nevina this is great
fantastic work
um without further ado i think we're
going to try meteor
uh there's two things we need to do
first of all matthew if you can
exactly as